foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
musical scenery sounding like phrasings
like that's very like sondheimer I think
what which is like this little chord I I
don't know I mean I don't know enough
about music to know but I feel like this
is like I saw him in the woods oh yeah
laughs
standing alone in the woods
did he see you Carol no
I tried to look his way but he turned
and said goodbye
[Music]
I'm sure
we'll meet again one day but how
maybe I will pass them on the subway
and he'll look my way but he's blind
maybe he can smell me or he'll sense me
but he also lost his nose in the war
then he'll rub up and he'll feel me
[Music]
but he lost his sense of feel
see it ain't that hard
come on come on to a beautiful song
[Music]
uh now who are you who am I have we
started we have a God here we have this
guy here right here we have a guy here
now it's Jimmy deuts he's Jimmy Doyle
from season one that's right and season
is that what it was seven it was seven
it was seven French little Beauties
because Mac was fat can we can we see
cormic's face or is this mic too high
I want to make sure we're getting all
that that beautiful there you go there
we go you got it
yeah president composer that's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia yes Long Time Pal
I'm so excited to be here for I I just
gotta say that I'm so excited to finally
meet you [ __ ] me yeah you uh and I just
I you know it's just I I never thought
I'd be in the room with like
the three of you again just like with
the pandemic and everything and so much
has changed so but you never thought
we'd be in a room together again
yeah yeah yeah I don't want to tell you
but uh their odds were late that's
really that yeah since we've established
you wouldn't be Charlie because he's the
the healthiest
did we we did we did I won out right
the competition you get all the points
we are here today to talk about the
nightman cometh yes which um I had
forgotten to watch until this morning I
was like all right actually me too I did
the same thing I forgot and I was like
oh [ __ ] I need to uh and I have to say I
thought I just knew it all I was like
well I know it so well but there are
lots of surprises in there
again I think one of the best episodes
we've done I think fans have reacted to
it in that way let me give just a little
information about it just so you know um
of course everybody knows there is
structure we do have more we do have a
tiny bit we forget about it but there is
structure to the podcast yeah right
Megan has insisted you have such a good
job on this thing
it's already hard to get her head
through the door okay well uh nyman
cometh is season four episode 13 it
aired on November 20th 2008 which means
next year around this time it'll be 15
years since it aired uh it was written
by Charlie Day Glenn Howerton and Rob
mcelhenney and directed by Matt shackman
and music composed by Cormac Bluestone
and Charlie in so many ways it feels
like it was yesterday I feel like we
just shot that I have so many memories
of shooting that episode and it was 15
years ago but I want to talk about how
that thing begins unless you guys have
got something else you want to put on
the table how the episode begins or or
how how we conceived of it both because
they're connected
uh yes yes they are the way the episode
begins you know I'm in the uh in the
back room and you hear me start singing
a song like come one come on for a to a
beautiful to a beautiful show it's gonna
be awesome
some other musical stuff and then you
guys are icing me out and then it's a
whole conversation of why would you
write a musical just to write a musical
who is it against what's the uh who's
the mark and of course ultimately it
there is a ulterior motive in the
episode but that came out of the fact do
you guys remember we were trying to
break this episode we had a whole
there's a whole other storyline that got
broken yeah we decided to we were
kicking around like they were trying to
like break into a bank or something for
a specific reason and the musical was a
distraction while they were well jumping
back and forth doing this other thing
the other version of it was that there
was a rival bar
there was a bar that that we had some
kind of a prank war that's what it was
going with and they had pulled some kind
of a prank on us and we were going to
pull the ultimate prank bike but we
needed them out of their bar and in
order to do that we created a musical
and that we were all in the musical
because that would prove that like we
couldn't have done what they're saying
we did because we were all on stage and
then we were going to do a whole thing
we're like whenever any someone was off
stage they'd be going over to the Rival
bar to like so that was the ulterior
motive and then and and we were sort of
obsessed with this idea of like
well we can't just do a musical for no
reason like there's got to be some other
reason why we're doing it so then we
just decided Well let's just write that
in I I never knew that about what that
other story but just like as I've been
thinking about this episode so many
things like fold in on itself because I
don't know if you guys remember when we
did the tour of nightman cometh we
showed an episode
during that tour and it was the gang
reignites the Rivalry which sounds like
that storyline yeah you're right I never
put that together I never thought about
that because I do think that we had
always had this thing in mind of like we
should have some kind of a rivalry with
like a younger bar you know and yeah I
never put that together that no
storyline gets wasted yeah
one season it goes on a card and then it
comes out eventually it gets recycled
yeah around to it eventually yeah yeah I
was um
delighted with all the rehearsal scenes
before the play so I think what I really
remembered from the episode was the play
and the performance but
the rehearsals was like yeah because we
changed a lot of it I think what's
what's probably seared into our memories
more than anything is the live shows
because that's the most recent stuff
that we did even though it wasn't that
far removed from shooting the episode
you know we we have there was a whole
song uh there's a whole uh nightman song
that we had to cut from the episode
because the episode was just too long we
had to lose some stuff that uh made its
way into the live show uh it's nature
[ __ ] happens
as well uh troll in my hole oh right
there was it right right there was a
whole thing at the end where no the
transformation we wrote that song for
the tour because we just felt we were
short when we first had to perform
it's the opening opening song right
where I'm like where I'm he's like do
you like your voice in it like you jump
up this way I got a troll in my home
if we could find those
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta try to try hole
[Applause]
[Music]
my whole of an apartment
[Music]
I control your soul
that's my department
everywhere there's
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my department
everywhere there's
[Music]
some more
he's got a troll in his home
I would love to hear from your
perspective like what what your journey
was for that like what was the first
time we contacted you what was the first
piece of information you were given did
we give you a script have you written
music before our show before this
episode never had written music wait
what I've never written I've never
watched TV before right
no but you hadn't written music I've
never picked up before the guitar yeah
I'd never written for sunny it was my
first thing and uh I've written music I
mean yeah I was totally writing musical
theater and Charlie came to a show I'd
been doing a show in for years in New
York and when I moved to LA I brought
kind of the best of it and Charlie saw
the show and he was like
uh it was you know bar Hoppers yeah
you're like is that before you knew each
other no this is okay we knew each other
this was in LA like at the Saint Nick's
Pub oh my God Saint Nick and uh Charlie
after the show I was like oh that was
really good you know we're about to do
this musical episode we were I don't you
did not mean it this way but you're like
we were going to hire a professional but
we should hire you
that sounds like something Charlie
you know because I knew you I think you
guys had written the script you were in
pre-production for it and uh you talked
to these two and uh sent me a script and
uh you're like coming tomorrow coming to
Fox and we'll sit down and go through
everything and I was like okay I gotta
take my shot I wrote drafts of all the
music and then I came in and I recorded
it on a CD and then you and me sat in a
room for I don't know four or five hours
and kind of took all our ideas and
mashed them together I think I had like
loose versions of some of the songs you
had really strong ideas like like I
listened to them I'm like this was all
like little boy tiny boy little boy you
were like oh it's got to be song timing
I was like it needs a little form well
how do you guys how do you guys know
each other uh Williamstown uh summer of
1997 and where all of your friends come
from where all my friends come from yes
two apprentices and yeah and horns
people say that same stuff Hornsby
um
yeah
um
and then right after uh like when I
first moved to the city I had an
apartment on my own for a year and then
with a with another buddy and then the
year after I lived on cormac's floor for
uh as long as they possibly could until
they got rid of me uh get out it's like
there was a lot of that with you too
well it was a studio apartment too it's
like a room and a bathroom yeah and uh
so this dude in a sleeping bag on a wood
floor McCormick we did a lot of jamming
out a lot of writing funny songs
together I've played we we've played a
lot of music together yeah played a lot
of music together so yeah when we were
doing it I I'm sure in my mind I was
like yeah if Cormac wants to come on and
help
sort of arrange these in a way that like
I have a limitation I'm like I can do
some chords and be like here's a Melody
now what are the nine other parts doing
do you remember like you know in terms
of the the songs and what they were
about and some of the lyrics
I mean we were involved in some of that
right like in the because it was because
we were writing the episode together so
but but I don't remember how much
how involved we Rob and I were in the in
the conceiving of the lyrics of the
songs I don't know if we I don't
remember any of that because I would
imagine a lot because it's all tied in
right like I mean there's a dialogue
backstage about like you know you're
going for gasp and that's all
I remember talking about the the
subjects of the songs and then they
would go off and I remember uh us coming
up with and talking about just to be
clear yeah well we were trying to figure
out what would be a fun song for D yeah
and just coming across that yeah she
would just write it just yeah literally
right which I definitely remember also
um a few years later the bird that's
that's how the birds of war was is the
same idea which is yeah do a song and
then make the song about clarifying what
the song is actually about yeah he's
clarifying what you mean by the song
yeah yeah
that song I love and also in a similar
vein the very first song that Charlie
was referring to that he comes out
singing um come one Kamal to a beautiful
show was that scripted or was that just
you making that description uh
I I think the script was you came out
and said I wrote a musical yeah I think
so yeah I think that was like yeah I
think I think on the day you felt like
it needed more Pizzazz yeah yeah and so
you you just died yeah
um but um
a couple things wait uh I'm eating
because I'm uncomfortable yeah is that
an improv that was an improv right or
was that scripted that's like my
favorite line
yeah a lot of baby Snickers stuff in
there yeah baby Snicker run but I don't
know if that was in the lot just in the
live show or there was a baby Snickers
run in the episode that we cut yeah
there's a lot in the episode I was
watching last night that I thought I
thought was I thought there was more in
the episode yeah actually yes and a lot
of it we cut out and put into gag reels
a lot of it was just in the live show
and so I have this hazy memory of what
the episode was and it wasn't one of the
things I love is just how straight all
those rehearsal scenes are played yeah
no I'm obviously bouncing off the walls
but not in a comedic way and it's just
like purely angry way yeah like and you
guys it's all very natural and very
small yeah I like that too yeah we all
are are all like
we're not playing it for life it's just
like a genuine confusion about the boy's
Soul Thing and whether this whether the
scene is about a rape and yeah you know
like it's it's all yeah it's all played
very grounded yeah the uh Dennis can you
take a five just a little detail of how
you're holding your hand when you're
doing that feels so specific I'd like
you to take a five five I don't know why
I remember I remember working on that
there were so many different versions of
that where we just kept going back and
forth with like a five
five a five only yeah yeah all five all
five yeah yeah please be gone for five
five of the minutes there's so many
specifics there in those rehearsal
scenes though that feel like they're
taken from you know like the kind of
people that you meet in Small Town
Theater like that type like Artemis
please do not speak to the talent also
that's what it was detail about Artemis
when you say I could have Artemis do the
song in her head and she is so ready to
do it yeah just that look you know she's
dying to be in the play no you that was
that was a big impetus behind wanting to
do this episode was wanting to mess
around with the Dynamics of Community
Theater like having all come from
theater we were like let's let's do a
thing where we get to insert some of the
things that we remember from sort of the
corniness of like I remember that's
where the gum bit came from too we're
like are you are you chewing gum and
it's like he said no gum you know what I
mean like the teacher's pet was always
like he said yeah no he said no God yeah
yeah also um yeah those were often done
with just someone playing a piano like
that was there was no like orchestras
yeah
and the woman that we got Gladys who
plays Gladys who then Dennis recruited
to play his grandmother in the Dennis
system same actress yeah but she came on
and just started improving and just
talking about it whatever she was saying
and yeah it's in the bloopers yeah it
was unbelievable
those bloopers yeah those are always
just fun
this is Gladys she's gonna be playing
the piano instead of me tonight yes and
I will live through the Coolidge
Administration and I never thought that
I would ever be at my 99 years of age
being with such beautiful people okay I
love that all right now she knows all
the songs everything's fine why no why
there's a little last minute video that
happens okay and so Gladys can you just
get out there and get us started please
I'll try yeah well don't try just do
okay you've been sniffing at me all
morning
time
I can't do this okay
oh I've been through the Coolidge
Administration but I never thought it my
99 years of age I would be with such
beautiful people okay glad we don't have
time for like this time don't know
how much fun
I played Gladys she was born on May 13
1909 and she started her acting career
at the age of 93. and the the absolute
Pinnacles are flipping through the pages
when D sings her own song and saying
what is happening what is happening best
delivery of one of our most iconic lines
that we've written into a thousand
episodes what is happening it's our
favorite line
and she no one has ever delivered it
better than she did yeah yeah yeah I
don't think typically Iceberg
um she was amazing descending on a son
I stole that from Sweet and Low Down
where Sean Penn descends on a moon and
there's a great sequence where you know
he he wants to you know he's making this
big deal about like he's going to
descend on this Moon and then he gets
like
he's really proud of it and then the
stagehand comes by and he's like that's
a hell of a drop man could break his
neck you know and then he gets like
nervous in his his descend is so like
but I I was watching that because I
couldn't remember if we if I did drop
down or if I didn't cut away but we like
cut away and we could cut away so quick
yeah but now that we do we're coming
down on it you see it for like a half a
shot I think you're strapped to it so
you had to cut
yeah get unstrapped and then come on
that's what it was a technical thing so
remember there was a big debate
about uh whether we would sing this live
while recording it or we would lip sync
to pre-recorded versions of the song
right that was one of my first things I
think I said when I came on because I
had so much experience and stuff I was
like we got to do it live and it was so
funny
when we did it uh it's just so much
harder to do it live no one ever does it
our playback guy on the episode we gotta
have a click track you gotta have got to
make sure that the rhythm is the same
and everything those hair pieces are
really expensive too it's tough so
editing wise yeah the playback guy he
had a couple Emmys he did like the
scrubs musical The Drew Carey Musical
and he kept saying to me what are you
guys doing you do the pre-records and
you lip sync this is ridiculous during
editing I was getting calls like they
don't know what to do with any of this
how does this all go together blah blah
blah what we cut together was a mixture
yeah of of us singing live when we were
filming and the pre-recorded stuff as I
recall we we spent a tremendous amount
of time well they built like a little
tremendous amount of time like yeah yeah
but the the the live performance aspect
of it is what makes it so funny like if
it was polished yeah it wouldn't be
funny it's the fact that it's unpolished
and you know people are singing off key
and like in those musicals they that
you're talking about the episode itself
becomes a musical versus right so the
scrubs for example yeah and you'd need
that to be polished and we've done
versions of that on this particular show
but this where you're putting on a
performance you have to do it live right
I think otherwise it's every single it
seems well I think these were the exact
conversations we were having yeah
we're professional you know that's right
[Music]
have you figured out that first
Christmas present yet well look no
further than doubt that's right down
there at your underwear are you telling
us to give people our underwear as a
gift because that seems no I'm saying
get get them a new pair from me undies
could I get some of my current onions if
they are me undies why why would you
even ask that well because of my
experience me and these are the absolute
snuggliest most comfortable undies in
the game maybe I'm sporting a pair the
recipient doesn't have yet right I don't
think that they'll want your old undies
once they get their new undies plus me
undies holiday collection also has
bralettes and PJ sets holiday sweater
prints classic plaids for dads and the
softest loungewear ever in sizes XS
through XL what if I am the recipient
well glad this year you're in luck
because me undies is encouraging you to
do holiday your way and if your way is
gifting yourself a bunch of underwear
more power to you just dispose of your
old underwear responsibility okay Glenn
we'll talk what does that mean sell it
on eBay ah to get 20 off your first
order free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies.com sunny
that's meundies.com sunny
guys I haven't announced these
announcement Glenn's got an announcement
it's a medical announcement from our
friends at raycon oh do you or a loved
one suffer from chew volume anxiety CVA
it's a very serious condition that does
not get talked about enough but deserves
to be especially with the holidays
coming up when you want to block out the
sound of annoying relatives chewing
their food or chewing your head off
about your life choices we here at the
Always Sunny podcast recommend that you
drown them right out with a sporty new
pair of raycon wireless earbuds I can
personally attest that raycons are the
perfect gift for anyone in need of
drowning out uninhibited chewers okay
even if it's a gift for yourself well
watch this pop these in here
there we go
um now right Rob yeah I'm ready why
don't you guys probably
I'm smacking you okay I'm smacking are
you guys pantomiming or are you actually
making noise plus you as the Gift Giver
will love that they start at half the
price of other premium audio Brands so
go ahead take a look at the Holiday
bundles for the fitness lover or gamer
or CVA sufferer in your life which you
can find in Kohl's or Walmart yeah but
why not try uh you know just buying them
from us your trusty friend so uh right
now you can go to byracon.com Sunny to
get 20 off or you could you could save
even bigger and get 30 off raycon's
exclusive holiday bundles that's
byracon.com Sunny for 20 off your raycon
purchase buy raycon.com sunny
foreign
[Music]
my little black Sailors cap that I wear
is a homage to uh when I was in college
and I decided I want to start doing
plays there was a theater Club not a
program there's like a club and they did
plays in like a church basement
and the guy who ran it was a guy named
Tom Kirkman and uh he like he used to be
a priest but he wasn't priest anymore
and uh or maybe he still was I don't
know but um lovely guy I really
appreciate him putting me in plays and
and you know but he always wore like a
little Sailors cap like that was like
his thing and he wore boots and he would
go
he would breathe through his teeth like
after rehearsal and he would go
that was
[Laughter]
that was his style anyway it's not the
story Fizzles out but a little a little
tipped old Tom Kirkman so I owe him a
set of gratitude how about troll toll
where did that come from well both
trotto and tiny baby boy came
a little bit from the musical I used to
do with Hornsby Paperboy
uh so up at Williamstown Hornsby and I
used to improv this musical about a
Paperboy movie
and Tiny Boy was Loosely based on a song
called like happy thoughts that he and
his or kind of funny thoughts he like
starts he gets a girlfriend he's having
kind of funny thoughts and then the song
gets darker and darker where they're
like you know like maybe we could also
get a ski mask and rob a bank and kind
of funny thoughts you know and then like
we'll shoot the clerk they're like yeah
let's shoot the cleric and you know uh
is playing against like a sweet song and
then troll tall was same like where he
Jimmy The Paperboy winds up in a bad
part of town and he's just like oh it's
homeless people who uh was the first one
who realized that hole and soul when
boys hole and boys Soul who who put that
together first that's all in all sounds
I think I I remember us talking about
that in the writer's room for sure that
was definitely something that uh yeah
that was like a big laugh in the in the
writer's room seems like a martyr and
Rose out there that is such a funny one
I mean that I mean I I I you watch this
episode it's like one of those episodes
you're like this is from that episode
this is from that episode this is from
it's just like wall to wall the jokes
um the songs musical it's great but like
there's just so much from this episode
the audience that we had in there I
believe we discussed this before Oh my
God who was that audience wasn't an
audience of people who had no and they
never heard of the show seen the show
they thought maybe they were there to
watch a play an actual play I don't know
but we I don't think we warned them we
just did it and I think there was a lot
of confusion yeah a lot nobody found it
funny
imagine if you had no context for what
it was that you were about to watch and
then all of a sudden uh that was the
play that was presented to you yeah I
think we did run it from start to finish
right yeah so we just over and over
we've just performed the play and then
it is what it is and then we did pickups
later and we shot it like like a live
show basically yeah and then we went in
for coverage and shot each moment and
each scene like we would in a normal
episode that was all shots I recall
those cat eyes like you can't see a
goddamn thing yeah in the live show you
just painted your eyelids that's right
because you can't see with those cat
eyes you can't see anything and they
they they're just scratching your eyes
you couldn't see through them so you
they give you just a tiny little eye
hole so you can kind of get this out but
really it just feels like it moves
around yeah it moves around and it feels
like it's just scratching your eye the
whole time so I remember when we did
troll told yeah I'd written this like
little bass line that you came in with
and you're like
and you had to talk and snap at the same
time
you're struggling with that I remember
oh I'm sure talk and snap but also you
you wanted him to snap but don't yes and
I was like in between and you were doing
yeah but what's so great about Cormac is
so patient he's so patient so for an
hour I I'm I'm trying to do this thing
and he's like you're doing great you're
doing great there's no way I'm doing
great after an hour and Glenn just like
well that's so funny because I remember
every time I saw him start I'd be off
stage like going really big yeah are
your stage
here I am 14 years later I realized you
couldn't see me I'm just like the crew
no but just knowing you were there made
me feel better also you you had to write
like
that's so funny I remember you writing
that whole bomb and then you had to do a
very specific thing just to get Danny
into the song which was like
like here is coming your time to start
singing
I do remember that yeah because he never
knew when to come in well I remember I'd
written like a draft of troll told it
was this loungy thing and you're like no
no no it's got to be like
like and I was like oh yeah we're doing
this for Danny and I was like oh it's
like a little Blues thing but of course
it just put all the onus on Danny like
like so many of the songs are just
lyrically lyric lyric lyric
you know it's just like jam-packed
wall-to-wall uh but yeah he on the tour
every night he would hit that but we've
had the whole band like just guys four
and everyone just go one two three
well I want to get into all the music
because as as you point out Cormac this
there's so much in this episode to get
to and um to that end I was really
nervous that I wouldn't ask all the
questions so like a big fan of this
episode uh would ask so are you guys
ready for the super fantastic questions
all right uh we'll just bring out our
our Super Fan um lin-manuel Miranda
[Music]
oh man wow wow holy [ __ ]
are you familiar with musicals oh my
goodness gracious do you have any sort
of sense long time first time happy to
be here
um yes I love this episode
um and I have so many questions I'm so
glad we have a composer here too wait we
have to talk about you for a minute no
no really I have to talk about you for a
minute uh so I saw Hamilton we were
talking about Hamilton yes yesterday yes
yes it was so exciting we were talking
about it yesterday and I was looking
over at Megan was like oh this is gonna
be so nice
I had no idea you were going to be here
and I was saying like like he didn't see
it without lin-manuel playing you didn't
see the music
and so I'm there we're in New York we're
watching the play and like I'm looking
at at you and you're like performing I'm
like I feel like this dude's looking
right at me but I'm like he can't he
can't he can't see me he can't see me no
I took my cat eye lenses out
man and then when uh it came time for
the bow you were doing the bow and the
whole place going nuts I was blown away
as of course and you you point at me and
Mary Elizabeth and you go holy [ __ ]
Charlie in the waitress
yeah you said it during he's like said
it in the battles like on stage
everybody else
and other people there on my way and I
was like oh Charlie in the waitress yeah
yeah yeah come on stage and then we went
backstage and we saw you and you were
amazing and and uh you loved Jon Bon
Jovi waiting that guy underwear
I think that's who it was yeah it should
turn bovine yeah you know Obama everyone
had to wait if I had more presence of
mind I would have turned to you and said
I was that baby boy baby boy it was me
well so that's right
is that right
now I came to thank you for all the
inspiration yeah well uh the nice thing
about you being here Lynn is that you
can answer once and for all um does
anyone write a musical for no reason uh
or is it always versus yeah it's always
versus what's the con the long con for
Hamilton and it was a six-year grift
um
no
um who were you writing that verses
I guess Jefferson
I wanted to ask you guys about your
history with theater and musical theater
because I know for me it was like that
was the place where I found any crust of
cool in high school and it was the place
like where like I could exist outside my
grade and I could exist like you could
collaborate on something that was not
just like the drudgery and horror of
high school right and uh so I was
wondering and then you know you guys
have chops I was watching the live
episode on the way here and the whole
inside my apartment bonus song where
you're just like wailing like yeah
Freddie Mercury like you guys have to
have done musicals at school I did a lot
of musicals yeah I want to hear the
entire biologist yeah I did a bunch of
like really random musicals that most
people have never heard of I did a
musical called
uh star mites oh wow do you know this
it's like that's like a very cult flop
music yeah yeah I don't know it I did a
music called celebration was written by
the same uh team that wrote uh the
Fantastics the Henrik and A Little Night
Music oh [ __ ]
um that was by far the hardest yeah I I
ever because I had to I had to play the
cello while singing an extraordinarily
difficult song yeah but sometimes like I
was playing the cello along and I was
like oh my God yeah it was it was it was
crushingly difficult
um yeah they're so much harder than uh
the nightmare cometh much harder though
yeah and Charlie what's your musical
background because to me your musical
background these things just make sense
to me
okay which is one of the best some of my
parents are music teachers yeah my mom
taught like kindergarten through eighth
grade and my dad like I was a college
professor and um
growing up I remember my mom
doing some Productions of of she she put
on like HMS pinafore and the Mikado and
um
and The Whiz and I was too young to be
in these things but I remember like the
eighth grade kids were doing these plays
and I would see them so I was introduced
to it then
in second grade we did uh sorry when you
say she put on she was like the musical
director of the school so like you know
she was a music teacher like you know
you're going to Mrs day's class for
kindergarten through eighth grade yeah
so then uh
uh I did a I did James the Giant Peach
and we did a musical version and I sang
that song like smiled all your heart is
breaking or whatever yeah it's the first
time I like had to like sit and like do
a song and then I didn't do [ __ ] until
High School
my senior year which I did South Pacific
but you were playing but you were
playing music I mean you were oh yeah I
started like I kind of rebelled against
it and then like once I got out of high
school I picked up the guitar I started
writing little things and then you
started that wasn't your first
instrument you were you playing like
yeah I had some piano lessons which I
ditched at 10 I played trombone trombone
and then I dis trombone and then uh I
picked up the guitar and I sort of have
to learn that and then back to the piano
but
um then I get to college and I do
um Sean Himes into the woods yeah and I
I'm just like the guy who goes like the
slotted spoon can catch the potato were
you the narrator nope just like a guy
like just a guy yeah uh but then I
started like
do you remember the Bravo Channel like
um of course before it was all this
reality show they would play plays yeah
and then they had into the woods on
there a lot it was like on a lot and I
would like get home after like hanging
out my buddies and I'd make myself like
a gin and tonic and I would watch like
into the woods into the woods I was like
God this is so good I didn't think I
liked this before and I really like it
now and so I don't know is that like
I've had a long relationship with
musicals but also never really been a
part of them
like never done one professionally yeah
don't have a huge desire to kind of like
like and don't like them yeah that's
what most people's relationships can we
talk about Stephen Sondheim for a second
because
um I I he's been referenced so many
times on this podcast we talked about
him yesterday I know he was a friend of
yours a mentor of yours wait uh you knew
him yeah oh God and he he just passed
this past year past November yeah you're
well
um and I I think our audience would
probably I don't know how how big a fans
of musicals our audience is but I I know
Stephen Sondheim only from what I've
heard about him from you guys and I've
watched musicals my whole life but I
never realized what a
like massive uh
piece of musical theater Stephen
Sondheim has like given to this culture
correct he was like he's yeah I don't
know what the analog would be in another
it would be like
Scorsese for film or it would be
Spielberg for film like he just
redefined it on his terms and the crazy
thing about one of the most remarkable
things I think about Stephen sondheim's
career is that his mentor was Oscar
Hammerstein II like adopt not like only
Mentor but adopted dad his his mom
dropped him off at Oscar Hammerstein's
house they were neighbors and he was
just like I don't want to leave don't
make me go back to my mom can I hang out
with you and he always said if
Hammerstein were a butcher I'd be a
butcher
um so he's mentored by like half of
Rogers and Hammerstein but his shows are
totally different you know
Roger Hammerstein wrote like Oklahoma
and South Pacific and these Sound of
Music like these very like
wholesome you know it kind of defined
what musical theater was but they were
also these very naturalistic musicals
and Sondheim took that and wrote Sweeney
Todd about a homicidal Barber or a
presidential assassin Musical and he
just you know I I think the the lesson
of sondheim's career is one first of all
it's like variety like he never repeated
himself and two he just never he always
just kind of took what you would say is
like that can't be a musical and he
would turn that into like the best
musical
um which of course brings us back to the
nightmare
it coincides with like the 70s just in
general like what film was doing you
know where you have like the movies of
the 50s and you have a lot of Happy
Endings or you know a much more kind of
big polished thing and then in the 70s
people start being like actually the
guys just go on a motorcycle ride across
the country and then they're shot to
death you know what I mean I think it it
really is was a reflection of who he was
one of the things Oscar told him in one
of his early musicals he started showing
us skirt stuff when he was like 15 years
old was you're trying to write like me
don't write like me if you write what
interests you like you'll be ahead of
everybody else that was his big advice
to young Stephen Sondheim how do you
feel about that I mean do you do you do
you probably agree with that sentiment
sentiment clearly man I know that that
that for us was always our guiding
principle was you know let's just do
what we think is is funny and hope that
other people like it you know because
it's our best shot at making something
original
since there's only us you know we're the
only people that could conceive of
something that only we can conceive of
so let's do that yeah to bring it back
to the night man cometh and you're
talking about pursuing just kind of what
you love and and making that to keep
things original what's interesting to me
about this is it's a musical that you
guys made and you usually I imagine you
Workshop musicals in front of audience
so you have some idea of how they're
gonna hit once you get to like the big
venues but you guys made and recorded a
musical and released it to the world and
it's fully finished form the only way
that it will ever exist and I have a
follow-up question about this because it
also emerged on what looks like the most
insane Chicken Scratch pile on a paper
and then gets translated by Artemis into
English
so I'm curious well I'm curious how you
guys Workshop the musical among
yourselves like how do you find
well boys hole boys I mean the beauty of
what we're doing is like you have an
absolute
bailout parachute with a joke right
which means we don't have to do anything
in Earnest which means that we can fall
right flat on our face like yeah sure
there's a piece of me that is always
like yeah I'd like to write a musical
that'd be fun I don't have the guts and
balls to actually write a musical and
put it in front of the world but if I
write a musical that's a joke about
musicals then I'm safe right and and
kind of like our our show is such a good
sort of like um practice like play box
for a Sandbox like playground for kind
of trying things which is like I'd like
to write a David bowie-esque rock song I
can do it on our show or like I want to
try an English accent but it's it can be
bad yeah yeah you know like I do have a
question about the English accent which
is your accent as the night man it's
very David Bowie and Labyrinth to me
yeah I have no idea I'm just gonna keep
up I'm just trying to keep up I can't
remember
there's something quiet about it that's
very like David Bowie is Gareth well
love
thank you yeah uh do you want to write
another musical are you is that he's
always writing you're never gonna not
write musicals yeah that's I I've worked
really hard to get good at it
and so I wanted you yeah doing it and
but but the thing is always like finding
the idea that pursues you like it can't
just be you know I've written ideas
where I've I've written my weight and I
go oh I think I'm done like I'm not
interested in pursuing this anymore
um that's what's so kind of beautiful
about this episode is you can tell in I
mean just in the context of the story
Charlie was possessed by an idea and he
saw it through like he actually did
something very impressive and the the
side of Charlie that this unlocks in the
episode like when he is screaming at D I
mean we have never seen Charlie like
that full theater Tyrant full so explain
to me where the full theater Tyrant came
from because I think that's just a funny
concept but he's just so powerful yeah
like like and Charlie's never really
powerful don't you feel like that's a
dynamic that happens in the theater like
I'm sure Glenn you've seen it like in
the Juilliard days where it's just like
this extreme tension about this
ridiculous thing that people are doing
but also underneath it I feel like he's
trying to get this girl to marry him and
it's like everything riding on it that's
what I mean like right he's like I I
need this play to be good last shot
because it's my last shot I'm going to
propose to this woman there's moments
where your IQ goes up a hundred points
yeah yeah like when he goes through Turn
the Page over
nothing that's what you'll sing yes
I want to play this section
Charlie this is my big song yeah
you
sorry D um look at your ringing your
hands let's see was it did
write it Charlie with it no Charlie
wrote a musical and came to D with it
and the Gang and the Gang likes to screw
it up and make it about themselves and
take it away from church
so let me tell you something dude let me
break down a scenario for you I could
cut the song okay because I wrote it I
could have Artemis do the song okay
strap that away and I could do the song
myself so you tell me Little Miss all
that what do you want to do a song or no
song like a funny thing happens when
you're doing a scene like that where
like I'm just screaming at Caitlyn right
and I feel her feeling screamed at like
I can feel her starting to be like well
he is whether it's the actor or the
character this man is [ __ ] screaming
at me yeah
and I can't like soften that blow I
can't be like all right well let me back
it off a little bit because she's
getting upset like I got a stick in it
so like I have to like turn the nice
side of my brain off
it's funny because you're giving her
exactly what she needs as an actor by
doing it
in your mind you're like I'm upsetting
her I know I know inside of you or
you're like this is abusive in a way
yeah but of course in Caitlyn's mind
she's like oh this is great like is it
right I am getting screamed out and
that's how I'm supposed to be reacted so
it's a good genuine reaction she plays
it great there's nothing more abusive
than the level of stalking that goes on
in this particular episode
of the waitress and even even in the end
when you're like well I'm coming yeah
yeah I didn't sign anything so don't
come back tomorrow that is Sinister
completely wrong and yeah and yet people
have really used that song as a proposal
song I've seen YouTube videos of people
literally proposing in real life using
about that in the podcast
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as you were saying you wrote it with us
out which is it's supposed to be funny
it's not supposed to be that good and
yet everybody loves it they love the
songs like you you somehow looped around
again to create something that isn't a
joke that is I mean this is the power of
music man I'm sure you have experienced
this is that did Regis people Beyond
but uh now I'm doing the George Bush
thing
I was
it was about
one time when I when I went to go see it
I just heard it was a hit uh I didn't
know anything about you I went to go see
it and
you know 10 minutes into the play I'm
like okay oh it's like we're rapping all
right
yeah and then by the end like it was a
completely oh it's Primal it's Primal
yeah it was like yeah that hit me in a
way that very few pieces of art actually
have and like
something about the power of combining
music
to whatever like if you nail it right I
don't know I know it hits you in a
totally different way even in our goofy
kind of like Hey we're doing a silly bad
musical the songs stick with me but you
know it's funny because I'm so allergic
to metamusicals like there's they're
their own genre where they're like we're
commenting on the fact we're doing a
musical isn't it so hilarious that we
are breaking into song
um I kind of generally hate that [ __ ]
like I'm just like stop apologizing for
the thing you clearly love to do but
that doesn't right that doesn't come
across in this episode like what comes
across is that Charlie earnestly this
show came out of him and he's using it
of course for sinister ends but it
doesn't ever feel like you guys are
commenting that musicals are bad no it
feels like uh Charlie is inept at making
what he wants to have happen yeah happen
and like the vanity of your characters
is always gonna offend you stage freeze
don't say stages
the joke isn't that Musical are bad the
joke is that we're bad at doing them yes
yes
the show no you guys are working your
ass off like when when the night man
comes out and he's he's finally doing
his Earnest awesome karate and they're
laughing
it's such a dejected little side I also
love the little moment where Dennis is
backing up to grab the gun and you you
don't want to turn around and grab it
because you want it to be subtle so what
you do is you flail around behind you
for someone holding it like just uh
through the door for you that's a little
detail I think that again it brings up
like it invokes such high school
productions and it's so nostalgic to
watch like even the sets and the way
that the couch is painted onto the wall
and the yeah everything it just has and
then contrasting that with the subject
matter that you're talking about it's so
dark
do right on piano when you go you sit on
a piano and yeah I don't I can't play
Trombone
no I only ever learned piano took pen
lessons as a kid and so I I have my
keyboard hooked up to my computer and
I've used I use I wrote in Heights like
on GarageBand like use that to arrange
it and then uh graduated to Logic for
the subsequent shows we talk about your
process for a little bit um because I
found it fascinating when we were we
were in New York we went out to dinner
and we went to see a comedy show and
then
um you were like I gotta get home
because I found this fascinating he said
this to me at dinner I said I can't stay
out too late tonight because I got to
get home because my boss is expecting me
to deliver a song by the end of the day
tomorrow and I thought he was joking and
I laughed and he was very serious and I
was like who's your brother I'm serious
I mean he was like but you were you were
Earnest insofar as you had to deliver
this to your boss and I was like
who is your boss and it's the head of
Music at Disney what's his name was also
everybody Atomic Google yeah he runs he
runs music for Disney and I was writing
a song on uh for an assignment for him
yes and and I just found that
fascinating because to me if there's any
artist in the world living right now who
doesn't have a boss it's
however I but I found it interesting
first of all obviously you're respectful
of somebody who's paying you you're
professional paying you and they have an
expectation of delivery but beyond that
it almost felt like you enjoyed the
constraint of knowing that you had to
get something done yeah is that a part
of your process yes I think this says
more equal amount about you that it does
about me that you were fixated on my
having a boss yes because you're like
well I'm instantly resentful of anyone
who would call themselves my boss yes
boss yeah aren't you yeah
you don't have to say yeah I love a
deadline yeah that's what I love and
when I'm when I'm working on something
to know that we're going to meet about
what I write every week that's the best
way for me to get anything done that was
how in the Heights got written how
Hamilton got written you know when I
started writing Hamilton I was took me a
few months to write the opening song
took me a year to write the second song
which was oh my God half just like not
writing the song and and half just me
not committing to finishing it and it
wasn't until Tommy kale got involved and
was like let's just put a date where
you're going to perform as many songs
from Hamilton as you can and that and
we'll just commit to that like seven
months from now and I wrote 11 songs so
that that tells me that like I need a
deadline to get anything yeah because
then you can just keep chipping away at
something at a certain point you're like
okay I have to move on and only when
you've moved on from it can you go back
to and be like oh it's not as bad as I
thought it was or it's even better yeah
and also I'm sure you guys are familiar
with this like my favorite part of the
process when I'm working on a musical is
bringing the song in and then being like
all right like here it is like guts out
like what do we think what's confusing
what could be better what did you like
what didn't make sense and and I'm sure
that's how you guys work too in terms of
like it isn't this I think this is a
great lesson For Young Artists and
people who are trying to get into into
creating anything is the idea of
iteration
um we talk about this quite a bit which
is oftentimes people are afraid to put
out to show people what it is that
they're working on at early stages
because they want to perfect it not
realizing that there is no Perfection
and like us so much a part of any
collaborative art is to get other
people's opinions and if you don't put
that if you don't have either an
external party who's putting on that
limitation or those guardrails of saying
we need it by this date then then you
have to do it internally and just say
look by the state I'm going to show it
to people and there's no that's not a
failure if someone says oh that's pretty
good but what if you tried this or what
if you tried that that's all a part of
the process and even the people who are
the greatest in the world at it like to
hear that I think like an audience
member to hear that that you also fear
that and also will sit down yet at an
early stage and show it to somebody and
take notes I think is really inspiring
yeah
you say the price of my War now that one
that [ __ ] number which is so [ __ ] all
that the the king's numbers are so good
did those come quickly writing wise or
those came away from the piano so this
came as like a tune in my head I was
actually on my honeymoon when I wrote
King George's song really yeah I was on
an island in the South Pacific with my
wife there was not a piano
anywhere now how do you do that it's
just in your head well I think the
reason it's so catchy and again like
your own
[ __ ] becomes a part of your process
like for me I don't have very good piano
tops so a Melody has to survive my chops
you know and so like that song was so
catchy it had to survive the two weeks I
was on vacation and stay in my head and
I wrote down the words as like I like I
put words to The Melody once it was in
my head and they were pretty close to
what the final words would be but I just
sang it to myself and it was just take a
video and it had to survive no no I
decided it just had to survive and and I
think that's why it's a catchy song in
the show like it was just stuck in my
head for two weeks but this is an
interesting song to write on your
honeymoon because it's about a very
dysfunctional relationship yeah well but
it's also a breakup song that's true
that's true like it's it's actually a
breakup song it's like no you'll you'll
be back you're stuck with me
so maybe no let's not look too deeply
into that yeah it's a perfect song like
every now and then I'll it won't even be
on I'll just like start singing it I
don't know why it's just in there yeah
it's in there for life now I think yeah
that's how a lot feel about the
nightmare yeah yeah yeah it really is I
mean it's trying to get it right in that
skull where it stays forever yeah yeah
you do have a knack Charlie does have an
act for writing very catchy melodies or
like catchy catchy things that just grab
you right away look it could have been a
good commercial jingle right yeah yeah
for sure the the lyrics to I think are
so catchy and almost because they're so
not specific like I'm thinking
specifically of the last song um if you
want to marry men will you marry me like
a little things that are added in yeah
it's not even Madness
when you wrote that did you mean like
were you calling were you calling her
man like but if you want to marry man
both or or was it like or if you want to
marry man I knew it would be funny I am
mad like it's also like a bad lyric yeah
yeah but like it's calling her man which
is also weird
do not phone me yeah what I love is that
it's it the beginning has like the
rigorousness of like a Bach cantata
there's like a chord for every note
it just gets it's like very like Feud
like almost and then it goes to the like
craziest Hard Rock place like that yeah
that's because we don't know what I'm
doing
[Music]
we are supported by athletic greens and
their delicious five-star lifestyle
friendly green powder ag1 all right you
know what I can start this time have you
guys ever counted uh all the way up to
75 to 75 like just
what do you mean just because well yeah
I guess there's a reason that's because
that's the number of uh high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens and
ag-1 you know um I'll be honest with you
guys hearing 75 of all of those things
every time we advertise for athletic
greens it kind of becomes like this uh
sort of amorphous blob of a number but
you know when you break it down and and
count it out one by one I mean that is
that 75 is a lot of nutrients yeah and
they're all together in one place all
together in one place and it's hard hard
to get any group of any size together in
one place it's hard enough to get the
four of us together in one place yeah no
it is that's why we have to do this
remote thing to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com sunny
again that is athleticgreens.com sunny
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
foreign
makes no sense to me
sounds like a James Taylor song like
it's so beautiful without the lyrics on
top
[Music]
but uh but the tiny boy baby boy is a
total Sondheim ripoff with those kind of
chords like right because it's a two
chord Jam but the chord on top is very
it's a major seven major seven yeah well
I don't know these words you're saying
that's the thing that this is why I
never pursued music because all that
[ __ ] I can't I can't get that [ __ ] oh
yeah that's perfect I could
it's just names for what you're doing
right right that's really all it is yeah
[Music]
would never use like a major chord when
he could do like a weird seventh chord
or a second or a fourth like he just did
interesting voicings at the end of the
end of there was a lot of that kind of
like
I get a
course yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
or maybe this is why I'm too far yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
for a rabbit
I don't eat rabbit so wait but we should
but take me from you finding that very
sondheimi and right hand to the call and
response of ooh well that's what's going
back
and that's like where your Dynamic comes
in Gray it says I can be like okay
here's some you know and I was like what
is Glenn doing on stage at this point so
we added these little oohs and o's
that's like 80s like metal lyrics like
that is so early that's Journey if you
only knew what I do to you but it's set
against this is insane yes
if you come for insane you've come to
the right place also so much of what I
love about this episode is you know
those rehearsal scenes before the
musical begins sets up so many jokes
that pay off like Dennis and Max
switching and then that paying off in
like the the hug that they do that's
very awkward it's a sexually charged
sexually charged Embrace
um but setting up those things and the D
wanted to throw in a song and then
having those things all like pay off uh
during the music did you guys write D's
Solo or is that McCormick did write that
yeah yeah
just just to be clear like clarifying
you know the previous song and I think
I've written it more like a song like
just to be clear I did not write that
song and would never have sex with a
child just to be clear just to be clear
that's like a Taylor Swift
I was thinking about when we were
writing this one of my concerns when we
were kind of writing it was I hope we're
not our goal here is not we're trying to
write a bad musical bad I I think we're
trying to write a bad musical as well as
we can as well as time yeah no no the
Muse has visited Charlie well I mean
that's because there's the piece of me
that is dying to
be in musicals sing songs write songs
and then there's the piece of me that's
it's too insecure to ever like really
pursue it so it's that sweet spot of
like well if I just earnestly do it and
then we make it funny then you can get
away with it but like um can we talk
about the troll toll songs and uh and
what that is sort of modeled after and
is there like anything special about
coming up with that I mean obviously
soul and boys soul and yeah boys so it
is a two lyric song and yet
devastatingly effective yes yeah yeah
I've got to pay the troll toll to get
into that poison and then they say
What's that name
I just was just playing the chords I
knew and so I was like okay the you know
the the major chords of the love songs
and the minor chords are the bad guy you
know so it was yeah it was like as
simple as like a bluesy kind of like uh
I heard that I was like oh this is a
blue nothing
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
that's a good thing that can work in any
musical really just saying what'd you
say hey hey
yeah and then what was what was Danny's
reaction to this how was what was his
level of Danny was gung-ho to do it but
he a little I had it's the craziest
story and I'll say it as quickly as
possible because I I met Danny a few
times but so we show up at the high
school because we did this whole thing
at one location and the night before I
was nervous I was like what else can I
give these guys to really make it click
and I thought lyric sheets we have the
script we have the music lyric sheets
just the song a page with lyrics right
so I sent that off to the second ad and
they printed them out and I meet Danny
and we run the song once or twice and I
turn around to my piano player I said
look Danny let's do it one more time
this time and I turn back and he's
halfway out the door and on his way out
he grabs some papers off my music stand
and just takes everything and
disappeared for the rest of the day and
of course and I thought I I thought you
were all messing with me because I swear
to God every single cast member and
every single crew member all day were
asking me hey any more of those lyric
sheets around and Danny just taking them
out the door so of course Danny like
slays it the next day when we record cut
to a year later when we did the tour or
when we were rehearsing for the
Troubadour I go we all went over to his
house to do this first rehearsal I bring
my piano player in I really like brings
us into his to their piano and she's
like oh you can just clear some stuff
off and work here and I remember picking
up a book and there were all the lyric
sheets and music marked up he brought it
home he'd worked on it which is like why
do you have to take everybody
yeah
yeah he wanted us to fail he's the goat
man I mean he like he he worked on that
stuff and he he's so amazing he he like
just killed that stuff and uh seeing
that stuff at his home like a year later
I was like oh this is a guy like you
know he wanted to rehearse it nude in
the 70s
you know he was also you know one of the
most delightful things about Danny is he
still continues to approach things like
uh with a youthful exuberance you know
what I mean like like he's okay to not
be necessarily the best at something as
long as he's having fun like he he just
has this like childlike you see that
information where he gets assigned to
the troll and he's so excited yeah one
of our comedy tricks is always like
trying to subvert the expectation so
you're expecting him to be pissed that
he's going to be the troll and like
offended yeah right right the second
he's excited you're like well there's a
joke right his entire social media
presence is based on him taking pictures
of his feet in different locations and
calling it troll foot in New York troll
foot in Paris and it's just that that's
how much he's embracing before me after
the musical that came after them that
was that oh that was right yeah well
after yeah yeah okay yeah David becomes
night man Danny DeVito became control
man I mean this this episode was truly
um the first this was our our way to
understand how the audience
at large was experiencing the show
because there was no social media at the
time right there was no we were making a
television show so we did nothing live
we had no indicators as to whether or
not people were watching the show or
enjoying it uh we had no interaction
with fans other than other than out on
the street or like Nielsen ratings yeah
yeah so the very first time we performed
this
um was at the troubadour and it was
mind-blowing we had people like who knew
every lyric to every song they knew
every line in the episode and they were
laughing before we were delivering them
to work in television and to be able to
go out and to to perform live what a
gift what a gift that you get to see on
a nightly basis how things are being
received although I guess like when
you're doing a play obviously people
aren't singing along
um have you played like some concerts or
some venues where people have had the
opportunity to sing along I went to a
show in London of Hamilton uh six months
ago the entire theater sang Everything
Hamilton was a really interesting case
because I remember when no one knew the
words when we started previously and and
people were going out and sort of
talking about the show and watching that
front row slowly become like the live
teleprompters over the course of the
first year because we didn't release the
cast album till like a month after we
opened on Broadway and that was our
ambassador more than the show was you
know you can only serve 1400 people at a
time on a given night but then the way
that album went out into the world was
really like
totally unexpected and then and then it
went from like we're showing you our new
show to reading on Twitter like whatever
line I [ __ ] up that night they're like
we saw it tonight
[Laughter]
is there another example and and uh
forgive me for not knowing but like of
the person who's writing the musicals
starring in them like has that been I
mean I'm sure it's been done a few times
but like
Broadway Broadway hits where the person
is also the writer um there
it was very much the case in the
beginning of musical theater like George
M Cohen famously did that like he wrote
Yankee Doodle Dandy and starred in
Yankee Doodle Dandy
um and then there were and now it's more
of a thing like again like Sara
Bareilles like when it wrote waitress
then went into waitress she's amazing in
it
um
there's a young theater writer named
Shayna Taub who's like incredible and
starring in her own shows so
um yes but it's it's it's rare it's part
of what's so electric about seeing the
performance right it's like yeah but I
mean for me the hope is always that it
lives beyond me like well yeah you know
that's that's the the hope is you just
write something really good that lasts
um I love in the Heights and I remember
seeing that um I I remember thinking
what's gonna happen when this guy leaves
a show and uh I mean it's a terrific
show it lives on the movie's awesome but
I remember seeing you and thinking what
what happens when Lynn maybe because
yeah
and then when you were at a drive-in
about to get into a fight yeah the words
you heard that story I did yeah
yeah but he heard piragua and it brought
him back
and that is the power of your music yeah
so okay troll told I want to hit every
song in this I'm sorry no no I I we have
to be thorough so thank you um so we've
done little baby boy and just to be
clear so I think Dayman is next time
which was in the previous episodes
the whole show was built around this
particular song which is really just a
chorus twice which is smart right but
wait a minute but when you watch the
episode there's also like um like you're
saying other stuff like it builds to
that was Cormac so like you've got some
Counterpoint going on yeah I don't know
what Danny exactly is doing but like
you're doing like
yeah yeah like you did add stuff to it
we I I just again it was like what is
everyone doing during this and I I
really like harmonic music when
everyone's doing stuff and uh so I just
arranged changed it and got there on the
day and I think we cut half of it just I
I overrode it and um and we cut some of
it we we added
um I am the ruler of nine and darkness
oh yeah master of bird and song a master
burden song yeah right and then um
you are the teacher of bird and man the
winner of contest near and far yeah
winner of contests near and far bird and
song yeah yeah so that was kind of how
we like wrapped up like it's not a part
of the song but the lead into that I
really love because it's that song
starts the third act and D gets us up to
speed by saying uh you once were a boy
and now you are a man and I am in love
with you and that just gets us like pass
that's right like that's the resolution
now let's get to like yeah
the chord progression also reminds me of
from the original one it was they hate
you night man and you don't belong to
them oh yeah yeah which was me just
riffing on the day and I miss your code
the voice comes back
well that at the end when I come down
and I sing the final song where I
explain the tongue in the back of your
throat thing you're doing there it's uh
Christopher gas I installed for
Christopher Guest it's from oh from
waiting for Goffman from a scene that I
think was cut from wedding from
government so it's in like one of the
songs he sings in the outtakes
it might have been a penny for your
thoughts oh God
yeah or maybe it's in the okay
for your dreams
the cut stuff in government is better
than most musicals
there's a big government influence in
this episode too oh yeah for sure like
the seriousness of a play that's not
good it's very fun right right
yeah it's uh well that transitions into
the last song really which is your um
proposal song
um where you descend and and quite a
piece of stagecraft too you descending
like it doesn't seem like that big of a
production and then you somehow
no and then Mary Elizabeth is flipping
through the pamphlet to be like wait
this is another song
now we made a very very very big mistake
uh when we did the live version of this
show we thought we had to we had to
stick uh to the truth of the Canon and
in the episode she says no of course and
storms out but when you when you pack a
room full of 3 000 people and Charlie
comes down and she and he's singing the
song will you marry me will you marry me
we put Mary Elizabeth out in the crowd
yes and we put a spotlight on her and we
had her say no
huge mistake the audience
even that like I remember the first time
Mary Elizabeth was like Hey guys like
you know they're like really vicious
safe out here yeah yeah yeah all we had
to do is just have her say yes just have
her say yes it doesn't matter yeah
they would have gone crazy but I do love
in the episode after she says no there's
a really sweet moment where Frank says
to Charlie like she's not worth it man
yeah I like he's comforting you I
thought the Raves team went really well
[Laughter]
that's a great musical Jolly he did a
great job
ain't worth it
[Applause]
especially nobody just writes a musical
for no reason I am here I am I am past
here
and by the way
I thought the rape scene went really
well I I am here I'm here with it and
that was awful for me and if you bring
this up back to the apartment tonight
I'm going to smack you I swear to God
well we got to do another season of this
show we're going into season 16.
um if you ever want to write a musical
um I would not possibly presume to
improve on this incredible atmosphere so
it is Disney it is a Disney show now so
it's on the family we could call your
boss we should call your boss Tommy is
Tommy his name Tommy Tommy Tommy
wouldn't even know what it was long
give us lin-manuel
we only need them for a week now
[Laughter]
get him off the stage Tom
get him back at Hollywood
come on let's write a song right now
these things just make sense to him
now we'll wrap or something
look you'll make 125th of what you make
no okay but it'll be a lot of fun for us
yeah I think it'll be less than that
actually less fun yeah we'll talk less
money
we're working out with Tom and Tommy
will let him know yes
you don't have a boss yeah I cannot tell
you how mad he got when I said you don't
have a boss yeah yeah there's no one in
the I was you have a boss I was
frustrated you wrote Hamilton why are
you ready you don't have a boss man can
I just break this down for you you don't
have a boss
is that right yeah lin-manuel doesn't
have a boss let me tell you about his
father's decks
but I think you're right you did
rightfully say like I think you're
talking to yourself man like you're
getting very worked up about this and I
was like maybe I am yeah yeah it was it
was like uh sort of just you're ready to
meet out Justice
too yeah Rob justice justice at our
dinner yeah who told you you have a boss
you want to write Rob Justice real quick
come on I know you can do it I think
it's very telling um that somebody else
who reached out um about nightman and
then became a fan of the show is Bobby
Lopez yeah
um is a big fan of Sunny which is really
cool like to hear that two I mean Bobby
is one of the other giant pillars of of
musical theater right the Mormon
incredible Frozen and the fact that he
really enjoys what you guys do is is
awesome he said uh didn't he also do
Avenue Q yeah that was his first every
he said he'd watch nightman cometh every
night he was in rehearsals for Avenue Q
oh my God yeah it's crazy wild yeah you
guys it's it's about putting on a show
like it it hits the same sort of like
pleasure centers in your brain that
Goffman does that like yes they may not
be great at it but they are doing their
damnedest to put on the show just even
down to the costumes like the
ill-fitting costumes it's just gonna rip
the pits but they can't because they're
expenses
do not rip that cognitive dissonance of
D dressed as like Princess Peach while
holding a coffee thing like yes it
doesn't make anything it was just like
Princess Peach that was always the idea
it's just like uh yeah that Prince
that's the Mario Brothers yeah
and then the day man being symbolized
with a silver like onesie and the Cod
piece
the day man nightmare yes obsession with
the but just your little improv of
taking the thing off and be like and I'm
a man
seeing yeah
well then this has been an honor to have
you thank you to have you here as well
could we play us out with some day man
just just pass out yeah
sorry
[Music]
um
[Music]
say stage freeze just do it yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
for everyone
[Music]
stage free don't say stage freeze just
do it